Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir sind wieder vor dem Salon.
Richtig.
Und müssen uns noch ein bisschen davor unterhalten über unsere Veranstaltung, die schon ausgebucht ist. Sag mal, wie schnell lief das?
Ich hab die Meldung bekommen, ich hab den Podcast auf 20 Uhr getimt und 20 Uhr neun an dem Tag, es war der, also als wir den Podcast veröffentlichten, 20 Uhr neun hat schon der erste gebucht und dann war am Abend drauf schon alles ausverkauft. Also die 200 Plätze sind vergeben und alle, die ne E-Mail bekommen haben mit einer Bestellbestätigung und die dann den Bezahllink und so weiter sind dabei. Und alle weiteren, ich hab dann den Veranstaltern da gesagt, in der KS, schickt mal gar keine E-Mail und keine E-Mail-Bestätigung, denn wir können das auch hier im Podcast dann ansagen. Es entsteht jetzt so ne virtuelle Warteliste. Also wenn jemand relativ früh, nachdem es ausverkauft war, noch geschrieben hatte, bekommt er einfach eine Mail, falls vorher jemand abspringt oder halt die Tickets werden dann doch so weitergegeben. Aber falls Tickets an die KS zurückgehen, wird noch mal die Liste abgearbeitet, sodass wir quasi eine Warteliste haben.
Das sagt uns aber, wir machen das vielleicht mal häufiger im nächsten Jahr. Also offenbar gibt es ein Interesse, dass wir auch mal in Präsenz Dinge tun.
Bei mir ja auch.
Deswegen, und bei mir auch sowieso, du weißt ja, ich bin ja nicht unterwegs. Und das ist doch zumindest ein sehr gutes Zeichen für uns, dass es ein Interesse daran gibt. Und dann können wir das 2023 auf jeden Fall mal aufgreifen, dass wir dann nicht nur eine Veranstaltung machen, sondern mehrere Veranstaltungen, vielleicht sogar in verschiedenen Städten, dass dann auch verschiedene Leute kommen können und nicht nur der Kreis um Frankfurt, obwohl aus ganz Deutschland, hat man uns ja gesagt, Buchungen kamen.
Das war ganz witzig. Der Mustafa von der KS rief mich an am Morgen und meinte so, ja die Tickets gehen weg, aber die kommen ja überall aus Deutschland. Seid ihr sicher, dass die dann noch alle kommen? Und ich so, na wieso sollten die nicht kommen? Na keine Ahnung, vielleicht wollen die euch nur so unterstützen und schicken deswegen Geld. Und ich so, nein, die werden dann schon kommen. Also die KS hat üblicherweise so ein 100 Kilometer Einzugsgebiet für das Kabarettprogramm und sowas da. Ist ja auch eine politische Bühne, was da sonst abläuft. Wir werden es dann am 20. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Wir werden euch natürlich dann auch fragen, wo kommt ihr denn so her? Und ja, vielleicht haben wir sogar ein internationales Publikum. Mal sehen. Also wir sind sehr gespannt. Das ist dann am 20. Dezember für unser Podcast die erste Gelegenheit, auf der Bühne zu sein. Und wie gesagt 2023. Bei der KS haben wir es jetzt so gemacht, es stellte sich raus, es ist gar nicht so kompliziert, es zu planen, wenn man so auf diesem Selbstkostenpreis bleibt. Das wäre natürlich für nächstes Jahr auch so das Ziel. In dem Falle ist jetzt die KS einfach der Veranstalter und wir lassen uns sozusagen virtuell buchen. Also wir stehen da dann auch im Programm in vier Wochen, wenn das veröffentlicht wird. Aber es ist sozusagen als Closed-Ding organisiert. Und nachdem ich den Orga-Ablauf jetzt einmal gemacht habe, denke ich mir, das kriegt man nächstes Jahr auch drei, viermal hin. Also das ist jetzt glaube ich nicht das große Problem. Allerdings, ich kenne nur die Veranstaltungsorte in Frankfurt. Also wir sind jetzt offen für Vorschläge, wo es erst mal nur darum geht, dass der Veranstaltungsraum einfach gut ist. Dass man sich da wohlfühlt, dass man da bequem sitzt.
200 Leute, 250 so als Grenze würden wir mal sagen.
Keine rein Bestuhlung, sondern vielleicht ein lockeres Konzept oder so. Sagt uns ja gerne Bescheid, dann können wir da anrufen. Und dann mit der Erfahrung, die wir jetzt aus der Käs schon haben, weil die Orga ist jetzt so weit abgeschlossen. Wir warten jetzt einfach nur noch, dass es dann im Dezember soweit ist, dass wir dann sowas auch auf die Beine und auf die Bühne stellen.
Ja, so wird das sein. Hast du das Merkel-Interview dir angesehen? Ich habe nur ein paar Minuten geguckt und zwar die letzten. Als ich nach Hause kam, sah ich es im Fernsehen, dachte ach, dann schaue ich mal kurz rein. War entsetzt über den Moderator Alexander Osang, der das schlechteste Hemd der Welt angezogen hatte, vollkommen zerkrumpelt mit einer Körperhaltung. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der da verwrungen saß. Es war eine Katastrophe anzusehen. Ich habe es also dann nur so im Hintergrund laufen lassen, um nur Merkel zu hören. Und ja, sie palliert, so wie sie immer palliert. Aber ich habe da jetzt auch nicht große Erkenntnisse draus gewinnen können, außer dass ich auch noch mal sagen würde, natürlich ist es nicht so, dass Merkel in der Hinsicht falsch lag, zu versuchen, weiterhin in einen Dialog zu treten mit Putin. So wie das jetzt manche tun, als sei irgendwie Merkel in so einer verrückten Russlandliebe blind gewesen. Das war sie keineswegs. Die Versäumnisse liegen woanders, ökonomisch, ökologisch.
Du bist also nach Hause gekommen und dann lief es schon eine Weile und du hast dann so ins Finale reingeschaltet?
Ja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dein großes Glück. Ich kenne das Finale noch nicht. Ich habe nur die erste Stunde und nicht die letzte halbe gesehen. Alexander Osang von der Ostsee Zeitung ist wahrscheinlich wirklich der schlechteste Interviewer, den man finden kann, insbesondere auf einer Bühne. Zuerst einmal das Berliner Ensemble. Vielleicht kennt das der ein oder andere. Ich war auch noch nicht drin, aber es ist dann bei Phoenix zu sehen.
Ich war ja vor wenigen Wochen drin. Wolfgang Borch hat draußen vor der Tür. Sehr schön.
Genau. Dann weißt du, da sind zwei Ränge. Es ist alles ein bisschen in Gold gehalten und so weiter. Es war volles Haus. Alle waren da wegen Merkel. Kaum einer wusste, glaube ich, wer sie interviewt. Also hat sich Alexander Osang gedacht. Dann werde ich zur Einführung in diesen Abend erst mal ein Text vorlesen auf der Bühne. Es war dann so ein Running-Gag, das Publikum schon so, soll mir jetzt eine halbe Stunde irgendwas zuhören? Ja, sollten sie. Und Merkel musste dann auch noch Scherze darüber machen. Und das habe ich auch gut verstanden, dass sie es dann doch ein bisschen lange hinter der Bühne fand, bis sie da mal rausgeholt wurde. Also in deren Sicht schon mal ein großer, also wirklich ein gigantischer Vorpaar fand ich.
Aber was war das für ein Text?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe ihn übersprungen. Ich habe mir gedacht, das ist keine Wunschfrage.
Aber das war jetzt nicht eine Einführung in Leben und Werk Merkels, oder was?
Ich sage mal so, vielleicht hatte der Text so eine Beziehung zu seinem, zu seiner Begrüßung. Er hat nämlich Frau Angela Merkel, mit dem Hinz, ich ist ja nicht mehr Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel, und dann sagt er explizit, meine Bundeskanzlerin wird sie immer bleiben. Da habe ich gedacht, oh wei.
Das ist ja übrigens ein, wo du das gerade ansprichst, also diese diese langen einführenden Worte sind Gift für jede Veranstaltung.
Ja, absolut.
Ich habe das jetzt auch schon mehrmals erlebt, dass man glaubt, man müsste, wenn ich irgendwo bin, mich ganz lange ankündigen und noch mal aufzählen, wo ich überall mal einen Artikel geschrieben habe oder so. Es interessiert erstens niemanden und die Leute, die sowas interessiert, die wissen das ja. Und deswegen, also man trägt entweder Eulen nach Athen oder langweilt die Leute oder tut beides. Und deswegen einfach nur sagen, hier ist sie, Angela Merkel.
Richtig. Die Leute haben Smartphones. Wenn ihnen das Programm auf der Bühne gefällt, dann finden die schon raus, wer da spricht. Und können denjenigen dann irgendwie folgen.
Sonst wären sie vielleicht ja auch nicht gekommen, wenn sie die Bundeskanzlerin nicht kennen würden.
Es ist eine neue Zeit. Also in der Hinsicht bitte keine Fehler auf der Bühne machen. Wir werden euch am 20. alle am Eingang schon begrüßen. Und dann sind wir einfach auf der Bühne und machen Podcasts. Also es ist so. Wir wissen dann, wie es geht. Wir lassen uns da nicht ankündigen. Na ja, gut. Die erste Frage an Frau Merkel war also, wie geht es Ihnen? Und dann sagte Frau Merkel, und das ist vielleicht der einzige Clip, den wir hier dann später noch mal hören werden. Ich komme endlich zum Lesen, jetzt wo ich Privatier bin. Und sie hat tatsächlich noch mal ausführlich dargestellt, dass sie während ihrer Kanzleramtszeit nicht zum Lesen kommt. Sie las keine Bücher. Und jetzt kommt sie endlich wieder dazu, ordentlich zu lesen. Und das ist natürlich irgendwie auch ein bisschen augenöffnend. Gerade für so einen Podcast, der sich Salon nennt und in dem nur gelesen wird oder Texte vorgestellt, also in dem der Text noch mal richtig Raum bekommt. In der Hinsicht werden wir uns das wahrscheinlich noch mal anhören. Und dann hatten wir ja in der letzten großen Folge, hier in der Mai-Folge, nicht geplant als Thema. Aber wir sind immer wieder drauf gekommen. Merkels Resümee. Irgendwer muss jetzt die Bilanz mal ziehen. Merkel macht selber Vorschläge. Sie schreibt ja gerade Bücher, in denen zumindest die Highlights ihrer politischen Entscheidung noch mal erklärt werden. Und wir haben ja gesagt, also irgendwer muss den roten Faden hier noch mal aufgreifen und naja, die Kritik zusammenschreiben. Und ich hoffe, das geschieht. Denn auf der Bühne, es war wirklich erschreckend, wie sie sich aus allem rauswindet. Es ist nicht gelungen, eine Sicherheitsarchitektur zu schaffen, die das verhindert hätte. Glücklicherweise, auch Zitat, glücklicherweise, hat sie allerdings alles versucht, dass nichts Schlimmeres passiert, als das, was gerade in diesem Krieg passiert. Und so betrifft es alle Felder. Natürlich hat Alexander Orsang, der nun wirklich der schlechteste Interviewer ist, sie nicht zum Thema Armut und so weiter gefragt, was ist mit der Bildungsmisere, sondern er klebte am Alltag. Es ging um die Bundeswehr und Merkel hat noch mal gesagt, aber wir haben doch in Afghanistan und so weiter, 20 Jahre lang waren wir da Führungsnation und keine Rückfrage zum Thema. Aber haben sie nicht 10 Jahre davon nur das Kämpfer verteidigt? Also sowas wurde da alles nicht besprochen. Es war nichts Thema. Gut, vielleicht wurde alles in der letzten halben Stunde noch verpackt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Dann ging es auch immer noch um Russland und warum sie denn so fasziniert sei von diesem Land und wie sie das dann trennen könnte. Und da sagt sie, naja, die Kultur eines Landes ist ja das eine und die gegenwärtige Politik das andere, was ja vollkommen logisch ist. Also wenn Frankreich jetzt plötzlich in Spanien einmarschieren würde, dann würde ja dadurch nicht die französische Kunst kaputtgemacht werden. Dann fällt es vielleicht, dann merkt man den Widerspruch einer Kulturnation stärker. Ja, der verstärkt sich, aber da können wir nun auch in Deutschland ein Lied von singen, wie das so ist, wenn man zum einen ein Beethoven hervorbringt und im 20. Jahrhundert dann auch andere Gesellen. Aber es ist wirklich so absurd, dass sie dann immer wieder dazu gefragt wurde, als wäre da irgendwie so eine merkwürdige Verblendung zu Russland, wo man einfach sagen muss, ja, sie ist natürlich DDR-sozialisiert, hat deshalb Russisch früh gelernt, dann ist eher der Kontakt erst mal zu Russland da. Ihre Liebe zur Amerika ist dann später gekommen, was ja vollkommen logisch ist in der Biografie. Und dann aber zu kommen, man kann das nicht trennen und fragte dann noch so, ja, und dürfen dann jetzt russische Künstler hier noch auftreten und dieser ganze Kram? Also was will man denn, will man jetzt einen totalen Kulturboykott? Es war doch eher blödsinnig, sich das Ganze anzuhören. Naja, und sie ist aber noch relativ gut dabei weggekommen, auch deshalb, weil der Moderator so unfähig war. Und dann hat sie eigentlich das Ganze noch so ein bisschen abgefedert und amüsant gemacht. Sonst wäre es wirklich eine ganz zähe Veranstaltung geworden. Nein, nein, nein, man muss vielleicht jetzt mal abwarten, dass diese große Bilanz gezogen wird und die bekommen wir aber nicht von ihr geliefert. Das war an diesem Abend jetzt auch deutlich. Also da braucht man jetzt nicht drauf zu hoffen. Da gibt es vielleicht noch ein paar interessante Anekdoten, die sie allen liefert, wo sie sich jetzt nach Jahren entschließt, die zu erzählen. Aber mehr ist da nicht zu erwarten. Also ich glaube, das Merkel-Buch brauchen wir im Salon wahrscheinlich nicht zu besprechen.
Nicht Merkels Buch, aber das Merkel-Buch, wenn es dann da ist von den Historikern oder wem auch immer, denn darauf verwies sie nochmal. Die Ukraine muss man sich jetzt nochmal anschauen. Das werden ja Historiker nochmal machen, ob ihr Fehler zu unterstellen sind in der Hinsicht. Der ganze Tenor dieses Gesprächs war im Grunde bezogen auf Alltagspolitik jetzt gerade, ist ja ein bisschen verständlich, aber in dem Maße dann doch nicht. Ukraine, wenn wir gewusst hätten, dass die Ukraine so ein cooles Land ist und gerade der Silensky und so weiter, also sie stimmt da voll in den Tenor ein, dann hätten wir die natürlich früher an die NATO aufgenommen. Das war im Grunde so ein bisschen, was man noch hätte raushören können in einzigen Halbsätzen. Sie möchten ein bisschen mehr reisen, zum Beispiel nach Bhutan, weil die da ihren Glücksindex haben. Dann fiel ihr aber im Abend auf, wir haben gar keine diplomatischen Beziehungen zu Bhutan. Jetzt braucht sie keine mehr, um da hinreisen zu können. Also wird sie das wohl irgendwie machen. Die Region Indien interessiert sie sehr. Also mal gucken, Helmut Schmidt hat sich China vorgeknüpft. Sie nimmt sich dann Indien die nächsten 20 Jahre oder was? Mal sehen. Falls ihr es noch im Ohr habt, LeFloid hat sie ja mal interviewt, der YouTuber. Und das galt bislang als das schlechteste Interview. Ich würde sagen, Alexander Orsang ist auf einer Ebene mit LeFloid. Er hat sie nicht gefordert, sie hat sich gelangweilt. Sie hat gedacht, sie muss jetzt noch für das Publikum ein bisschen was machen. Also hat ein paar Sprüche gemacht. Und anders als bei LeFloid wird es eine Fortsetzung geben. Es gibt ein zweites Gespräch mit Alexander Orsang. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Es gibt eine Fortsetzung davon?
Sie sagte dann sogar nochmal, und das war dann auch ihr größter Lacher im Publikum, ich kann mir ja meine, also mir wird immer vorgeworfen, ich könne mir jetzt meine Termine aussuchen und ich müsste mich nicht mehr überall und ich habe keine Verantwortung mehr. Da sage ich, ja das stimmt, ich nehme jetzt noch Termine, die mir gefallen. Und eine Minute später ging es darum, dass dieses Gespräch, was sie gerade führen, eine Fortsetzung hatten. Da habe ich gedacht, das ist ja alles komisch.
Ich werde ja immer mal wieder gefragt, worauf soll man achten bei Anzügen, wenn man mal einen Anzug kaufen will. Ich empfehle also da nochmal reinzuschalten in dieses Interview und zu sehen. So nicht. Also genau so sollte man nicht seinen Anzug auswählen und ihn auch nicht tragen. Gut, das war genügend der letzte Ein. Wir müssen noch etwas ansprechen. Und zwar bekam ich eine sehr schöne E-Mail von einem Hörer, der fragte, wie ich eigentlich unverzagt bleiben könne, angesichts dieser vielen Meldungen, die auf uns hinein passen und angesichts der Themen, die wir hier ja besprechen und wo wir auch noch zeigen, wie düster es mitunter aussieht. Und wirklich einen Tag später twittert Patrick Breitenbach vom Soziopod und von Critical Infinity. Ich darf einfach nicht mehr Neue Zwanziger hören. Mein Fatalismus-Meter ist sowieso schon hart am Anschlag. Dennoch empfehle ich die neue Ausgabe. Es geht um Antipolitik, Hunger, Digital Service, X usw. Danke an Stefan und Wolfgang für eure tolle und kluge Arbeit. Erstmal vielen Dank für das Kompliment. Und ich würde schon gerne etwas sagen, auch wenn wir hier nun wirklich kein Lebenshilfepodcast sind. Und ich will auch keine Lebenshilfe leisten. Ich bin ja selbst froh, dass ich mir gerade so die Schuhe zu binden kann. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass man ja fatalistisch werden kann in diesen Tagen. Wir haben jetzt diese enorme Aufrüstung, die ist beschlossen, ist jetzt durchgepeitscht worden. Wir haben eine Mehrheit, so zumindest eine Fernsehumfrage, für Atombomben-Stationierung in Deutschland. Wir blicken auf den Klimawandel und sehen, gut, das wird ja nichts mehr. Das ist ja eine Katastrophe. Man rüstet auf und stellt jetzt alles hinten an. Und man fragt sich natürlich dann, ist es nicht vollkommen sinnlos alles? Also das ist, glaube ich, eine Frage, die sehr berechtigt ist. Hat das überhaupt einen Sinn? Und was sollte man tun? Und vielleicht sollte man erst einmal sagen, ja, es ist eine gewisse Ohnmacht, und diese Ohnmacht ist auch real existierend. Das heißt, wir können nicht jetzt hinausrennen und sagen, nun Aktivismus, jetzt mache ich was. Das kann man machen. Und das kann man. Und man muss sich natürlich auch, wenn man aktivistisch tätig sein will, vernetzen, um das wirklich effektiv tun zu können. Aber tatsächlich ist es nicht dieses, ich gehe jetzt raus und mache das jetzt gerade. Wie ich jetzt sagen kann, ich schütze mich vor einer Krankheit, ich setze eine Maske auf oder so. Das kann ich bei so etwas wie zum Beispiel Klimawandel oder Aufrüstung nicht machen. Gegen die Aufrüstung kann ich jetzt gar nichts mehr machen. Also ich wüsste nicht, welche Demonstration man organisieren wollte, dass man sagt, man will das nicht machen. Und die Enttäuschung ist, glaube ich, auch groß bei jüngeren Leuten, weil sie ein bisschen dieser Idee erlegen waren. Und du bist es vielleicht auch, das will ich jetzt fragen, dass junge Leute in irgendeiner Weise progressivere Politik machen. Und jetzt haben wir diese, ich nenne sie mal TikTok-Hupfdulen der jungen Grünen, die alle für die Aufrüstung jetzt gestimmt haben. Die haben dann noch mal so Tweets veröffentlicht. Ja, schweren Herzens und bla bla bla. Aber du weißt natürlich, natürlich haben sie, also sie haben da eigentlich nicht mit gehadert, sondern sie inszenieren jetzt das Hadern für ihr Publikum. Und da fragt man sich schon, sind die Jungen nicht einfach genauso schlimm wie die Alten, nur sind sie halt jung?
Also wir werden noch über Jung und Alt reden. Ich möchte deine Frage gerne aufgreifen, aber nur indirekt beantworten, wie halte ich es mit dem ganzen Ding. Ich mache jetzt auch schon seit ein paar Jahren so Podcasts, in dem ich einfach aktuelle Sachen aufgreife, bespreche, kommentiere und dann Hörer zu mir kommen und fragen, aber was mache ich jetzt? Du informierst mich hier immer über Sachen. Und jetzt bin ich irgendwie so alarmiert bis hin zu aktiviert. Was mache ich jetzt? Und ich möchte mal das Bild beschreiben, wie ich das insgesamt verstehe, was hier so geschieht. Also in dem Moment, wo die Nachricht kommt, irgendwo in China ist ein Virus aufgetaucht. Könnte gefährlich sein, wir wissen noch nicht so genau. Und dann drei Monate später stellt sich raus, ja, so ein bayerischer Auto-Zulieferer ist irgendwie angekommen, aber die haben alle nur leichte Symptome. Und dann noch mal drei Monate später stellen wir irgendwie fest, oh krass, der Bundesgesundheitsminister sagt, 60 Prozent der Leute hier fallen in die Risikogruppe, weil dieses Virus hat ein Beuteschema. Alt, ungesund und so weiter. Ja, kennen wir ja die ganzen Zivilisationskrankheiten, die sich so durchschleppen, die uns sowieso schon schwächen. Und dieses Podcastprogramm ist Fitness. So wie man auch sich auf Corona sehr gut vorbereiten kann, mit körperlicher Fitness, ist das geistige Fitness. Das erfordert lange Wege und sehr viel Training, aber im richtigen Moment hört man dann, ach so, eine gesunde Ernährung schützt viel besser als eine AstraZeneca-Impfung. Man hätte nur rechtzeitig anfangen müssen, um einen gesunden Körper als Resultat aus dieser gesunden Ernährung zu haben. Und diese Studien sind ja dann irgendwann aufgekommen. Und dann stellt man plötzlich fest, Mist, dann habe ich ja Zeit verschwendet. Ich hätte vor drei Jahren anfangen müssen mit gesunder Ernährung. Und so ist das auch bei politischen Diskussionen. Man verfängt sich immer zu Weihnachten, wann auch immer. Man trifft so Leute, die man seltener sieht. Dann sind so Gesprächsthemen, auf die man ist immer nicht vorbereitet. Und plötzlich werden so Parolen gebrüllt. Und dann wirst du auch gut vorbereitet zu sein, um dann nicht nur Leute zu überzeugen und zu missionieren, sondern auch um sich besser zu fühlen, nicht mitgemacht zu haben in so einem Geschrei, das dann irgendwie entsteht. Und das braucht ein bisschen Anlauf. Dann hat man lieber schon mal drei Jahre lang in so einem Podcast gehört, dass es am Ende im Grunde nur um eine Erbschaftssteuer geht und nichts Komplizierteres. Weil dann fühlt man sich sicher und kann das einfach einwerfen und hält dann auch die drei Nachfragen aus zu diesem Thema, weil man den dann einfach beantworten kann. Und so sehe ich das hier auch. Das ist Langstrecken-Sport, das ist Marathon-Lauf, das ist langjähriges, langwieriges Training. Neue Zwanziger ist einmal im Monat. Also die drei, vier, fünf Stunden kann man sich ja wohl nehmen. Dann hat man eine höhere Geschwindigkeit. Wohlstand für alle. Man lässt sich so ein bisschen berieseln. Kurze Portion, ein bisschen häufiger. Und dann ist man so im Flow. Man hat dann einen Panoramablick auf die Welt. Man sieht dann das ganze Puzzle und ist nicht so überrascht von, wo ist jetzt die Schnittkanne von dem einen Puzzlestein zum nächsten oder so. Sondern man weiß ja irgendwie, wie es zusammenhängt. Und man muss ein bisschen darauf achten, früh anzufangen. Der Alfred Adler, dem ich ja jetzt so sehr anhänge, seit ich ihn über diese japanischen Bücher da kennengelernt habe, hat ja so einen Tenor. Man braucht immer die Hälfte seines bisherigen Lebens, um sich in den Zustand zu bringen, in dem man sein will. Wenn man mit 40 anfängt, ist man also erst mit 60 am Ziel. Weil es dauert 20 Jahre. Deswegen relativ früh. Und ich hab's hier, ich halte es dir an die Kamera, damit du es verifizieren kannst. Ich hab mir mal wieder ein Buch gekauft auf Papier. Weil ich dachte, das kann man mal so auf dem Nachttisch legen. Das ist von Christian Uhle und heißt, wozu das alles? Und ich hab's aus dem Grund gekauft, aus dem ich es jetzt auch nenne. Ich hab's noch nicht gelesen. Aber es ist eben, wir kommen nachher auch auf Philosophie und sollte man sie anbringen und ja, wie und so weiter. Philosophie muss nicht immer von Kant und Arendt und so weiter gemacht werden. Sondern es kann auch durchaus mal Christian Uhle geboren, 1988 Philosoph, lebt in Berlin sein, der sich einfach die Frage stellt, wozu das alles? Und dann ist es 400 Seiten Text. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es, oh ein junger Mann jünger als ich, soll ich das jetzt alles für voll nehmen? Nein, das lese ich natürlich genauso wie ich die ganzen Kant- und Arendt-Sachen lese, nämlich erst mal gar nicht, die liegen erst mal ewig rum, und dann blättert man mal so rein. Und ich finde, wir sollten jetzt mal den jungen Leuten, die noch viel Leben vor sich haben, die noch sozusagen skin in the game haben, wenn sie sich jetzt Gedanken über die Welt machen, Raum geben. Also Podcasts werden ja sowieso schon eher von jüngeren Menschen gemacht, also Menschen der ersten Hälfte ihres Lebens. Jetzt tauchen hier so Bücher auf von noch jüngeren Menschen, wo man so denkt, ja, die haben noch so drei Viertel ihres Lebens vor sich. Und an die sollte man sich halten und in dieses Fitnessstudio gehen.
Ja, ich stimme dir völlig zu. Und die Vertiefung in Themen, die einen interessieren, hilft sehr, mit der Welt zurechtzukommen. Die Versenkung in die Lektüre ist ungeheuer beruhigend, auch wenn man dort mitunter erschreckendes, irritierendes Lied ist doch diese Vertiefung etwas, was einen auch ganz anders durch den Alltag bringt und auch anders reagieren lässt auf diese kurzen Hypes, Skandälchen und so weiter. Und doch, glaube ich, müssen wir auch sehen, dass man nicht grundsätzlich von Jüngeren irgendwas Besseres erwarten kann als von Älteren. Und natürlich sind die TikTok-Hupfdolen genauso karrieristisch wie Generation Peter Altmaier. Nur die Generation Peter Altmaier hat uns Gott sei Dank mit TikTok-Videos verschont. Das ist der große Vorteil. Deswegen dann am Ende aus ästhetischen Gründen lieber Peter Altmaier als Emilia Fester. Da bin ich natürlich konservativ. Aber ich glaube, wir müssen diese Frage auch nochmal individuell beantworten. Denn das ist ja schon etwas, dass man hier zum Beispiel über so etwas wie Welthunger oder Aufrüstung spricht. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch den privaten Horizont. Das sind die direkten Begegnungen, Freunde, geliebte Familie, was auch immer. Und hier geht es glaube ich schon darum, und das ist jetzt ein bisschen Lebenshilfe, aber ich scheue mich nicht, geht es schon darum, dass man im Privaten auch eine Form des Hedonismus zulässt. Denn diese Begegnungen sind am Ende die, die man am unmittelbarsten mitgestalten kann. Und es ist auch, wenn man den ganzen Tag zum Beispiel nur Texte zum Krieg oder so gelesen hat, doch etwas anderes, wenn man am Abend in einem schönen Restaurant mit 1, 2, 3 Menschen sitzt, die einem wichtig sind. Und dann unterhält man sich vielleicht nicht über den Krieg, vielleicht auch, aber man unterhält sich dann über andere Dinge auch noch, und dann sind diese Begegnungen sehr wichtig. Und jetzt kann man sagen, das ist so ein Eskapismus, aber vielleicht ist auch dieses die ganze Zeit die Welt retten wollen eine sehr hilflose Geste, die einen auch mitunter nicht weiterbringen kann, sondern das gute Klima schaffen bedeutet auch tatsächlich im privaten Umfeld das gute Klima zu schaffen und bedeutet auch, sich persönlich zu präparieren auf das, was da kommt. Denn ich sehe tatsächlich mit Blick auf den Klimawandel sehr schwarz und würde jedem Freund, der mich direkt fragt, was ich empfehle, sagen, schafft ihr eine Klimaanlage an, noch sind sie recht günstig. Also um das ganz ehrlich sozusagen, es gibt ein Lied von Udo Jürgens, das ist nicht besonders gut, aber irgendwie hat es mich jetzt in den letzten Wochen immer wieder ergriffen, beziehungsweise es kam mir so in den Kopf, und das Lied heißt Sommer, und das beginnt so ganz apokalyptisch. Man sagt, die ganze Herrlichkeit ist schon das Ende prophezeit, man sagt, die Pessimisten haben Recht, uns beiden aber fragt man nicht, komm her, wir rücken dicht an dich und schenken uns ein Glas vom Besten ein. Man spricht von Sonnenfinsternis, doch eines weiß ich ganz gewiss, das nächste Glas wird nicht das letzte sein. Man sagt, der Tag ist nicht mehr weit, an dem selbst neu Schnee sauer schneit und nur noch Dreck aus allen Wolken fällt. Und dann ist aber die Wendung natürlich ins Private bei Udo Jürgens. Das ist eine typische entpolitisierende Schlagergeste. Ich weiß sehr wohl, ich kann das ideologiekritisch lesen. Aber dennoch ist natürlich auch hier, wie in jedem Schlager, das Körnchen Wahrheit. Und der Refrain ist, der nächste Sommer steht bestimmt ins Haus, die Schwalben wollen wieder hoch hinaus, die Schwalben fliegen hoch. Und ich glaube, dass man diese auch zulässt, dass die Schwalben hochfliegen können. Das ist schon auch wichtig. Jetzt ist aber genug der Lebenshilfe von mir.
Ja, okay, ein Satz noch von mir. Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, oder habe vielleicht auch früher so gedacht, heute nicht mehr, Menschen, die sich für nichts jenseits ihres Horizonts interessieren, führen so ein glückliches Leben, weil sie irgendwie durch Glück in Deutschland geboren usw. hier dann doch gut zurechtkommen. Aber wir haben jetzt die letzten Jahre gesehen, die Rhythmen, in denen die Welt auf uns einprasselt, es gibt dieses schäuble Ding vom Rendezvous mit der Globalisierung usw. das stimmt so ein bisschen. Wir haben eben solche Sachen wie, was weiß ich, die Kreditkrise da 2008 und dann 2014 folgen, so dieses ganze Griechenlandzeug, irgendwas ist mit dem Geld, dann kommt plötzlich Corona und dann kommt der Klimawandel doch mal zu uns, mit dieser Überschwemmung da im Ahrtal, dann passiert sowas wie jetzt in Russland. Und es ist nicht allzu schwer und immer weniger falsch, also verkehrt, so verkehrt das Verhalten, sich mit Sachen zu beschäftigen, die einem das dann instantan erklären. Wo man nicht angewiesen ist auf irgendeinen Neusprech in der Tagesschau oder so, weil die sitzen ja auch noch da in Suchenformulierungen für Leute, die möglichst runtergerockt sind, was ihr Weltverständnis angeht, sondern da dann kritisch drauf zu schauen und es sich auch ein bisschen selbst erklären zu können. Da ist immer so die Gefahr, dass man im Internet auch mal falsch abbiegt und dann hat man plötzlich so Welterklärungen, mit denen man, naja, so in verschiedene Milieus plötzlich eintaucht und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, man kann, also ich hänge sehr an diesem Fitnessstudiobegriff, auch für dieses Geistige auf der Höhe bleiben, sich sozusagen bereit halten. Ich will es nicht ganz in die Prepper-Ecke, aber so präparieren, wie du es eben genannt hast, das ist schon kein falsches Prinzip. Und es gelingt ganz gut. Man muss es eben nur so ein bisschen auf Dauer stellen. Also dieses Art-Hocke, das gibt es ja auch, irgendwas passiert, da liest man erstmal zehn Wikipedia-Artikel, dann ist es immer schon ein bisschen zu spät, wenn man plötzlich diesen Drang hat, wenn man sich was erklären will. Sondern man braucht so ein, ah ja, hm, okay, macht Sinn. Weil man kriegt es nicht mehr verdrängt. Also wir sind, wir sind nicht mehr die Genera- also das gingen die letzten Generationen, aber wir sind jetzt eine Generation, wir kriegen es wirklich nicht mehr verdrängt. Dieses Gespräch über Hunger aus dem letzten Podcast bereitet uns vor auf das, was nächstes Jahr passiert. Jetzt im Herbst. In Deutschland.
Und das ist, und das ist nicht mehr rauszudrängen, und das war in den 80er-Jahren oder 90er-Jahren noch gut möglich. Das merkt man auch, wenn man mit Menschen spricht, die um die 60 sind, wo das an denen auch vorübergegangen sein kann. Also ich hab mit einem Ehepaar mich vor einer Weile mal unterhalten, die Ende 60 sind. Und die haben einfach in einem Konkon gelebt. Für die war der deutsche Herbst. Mein Bader Meinhof, all der ganze Kram. Das war für die mal so, wie man irgendwie sagte, ach ja, es gab ja auch zu der Zeit, gab es auch die Rolling Stones und Abba. Ja, aber das war nicht in dem, also obwohl es in Deutschland stattfand, war das schon nicht mehr etwas, was groß an die rankam. Das war abends mal in der Tagesschau, da musste man Angst haben. Und da war ja mal irgendwann eine Polizeikontrolle. Da ging es, glaube ich, darum. Und mehr war nicht. Und dann war mal Ölkrise. Und da war mal sonst was. Und davor war es mit Kuba. Aber das ist alles sehr ausblendbar gewesen. Das ist in dieser Weise nicht mehr möglich. Ist eigentlich auch ein großer Vorteil, dass man sich damit auseinandersetzen kann. Man kann nicht dann die Last der Welt auf seinen Schultern die ganze Zeit tragen. Aber man kann sich mit diesen Lasten, die andere auch zu tragen haben, intelligent und in aller Komplexität auseinandersetzen. Das wollen wir jetzt im Salon ja auch tun.
Weil wir uns ja auch auf der Bühne ankündigen und so weiter. Wir haben diese E-Mail eingerichtet, die ist auf der Webseite. Schickt uns gerne E-Mails. Selbst wenn wir sie nur lesen und dann nicht auf jede einzelne Antworten und so weiter. Wir beide reden ja auch nur über das Zeug. Wir machen ja Podcasts füreinander und dann noch für euch. Wolfgang stellt mir gleich Texte vor, ich stelle ihm Texte vor und wir stellen sie gemeinsam euch vor. Und so wie ich Wolfgang antworte und er mir antwortet, könnt ihr auch uns antworten. Also das ist ja immer nicht ganz unbedeutend, dann doch mal so ein bisschen Resonanz zu hören. Wir sehen natürlich immer diese kleine Instagram-Storywelle und so, die dann durchschwappt, um den Podcast zu empfehlen. Das ist auch alles sehr gut.
Was sehr gut ist.
Genau, das ist sehr gut. Aber auch inhaltlich, wenn euch da was unterkommt, ihr seid ja auch immer alle Experten, wie festzustellen ist, schickt das gern, egal auf welchem Wege. Hauptsache man sieht es mal kurz und dann liest man es, antwortet vielleicht. Es sind ja auch tolle regelmäßige Begegnungen, die aus solchen Podcasts hier erwachsen.
Ja, es gab mehrfach die Frage von jenen, die den Salon noch nicht abonniert haben, wie lang denn eigentlich der Salon ist. Ich glaube, das war anfangs mal ganz anders. Da haben wir mal so 40 Minuten gesprochen. Inzwischen ist der Salon sehr lang geworden. Also wir sprechen oft so zweieinhalb Stunden, kann auch mal drei Stunden werden, über die Texte, die wir ausgewählt haben. Wir werden sehen, wie lange wir heute brauchen. Wir sprechen über zwei Bücher, einmal offene Rechnungen, der kalte Konflikt der Generation von Johannes Müller-Salo. Ein Buch, mit dem ich wenig anfangen kann, das mir aber auch, glaube ich, viel noch mal so erklärt, über den Debattenstand in Deutschland. Also das ist eigentlich diagnostisch wiederum sehr interessant, aber als Buch selbst nicht erhellend. Aber um drüber zu sprechen, glaube ich, geeignet, Virgil Horders, da werden wir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen konträr gehen. Ich mochte diese Polemik in großen Teilen natürlich schon von Catherine Liu gegen diese PMC, gegen diese professionelle Manager-Klasse. Und damit sind jetzt nicht nur die Manager gemeint in großen Unternehmen, sondern das sind alle die, denen es ganz gut geht, die von 68 jeden Weg gefunden haben, den Peter Sloterdijk mal aufgezeichnet hat, nämlich alle Wege von 68 führen in den Supermarkt. Wir werden uns darüber unterhalten, vielleicht auch streiten. Dann, wie angekündigt, dieses Buch über Streaming-Dienste und vor allem über Netflix. Großartig Identitätspolitik, Repräsentation auf der Leinwand, Ideologie durch Hollywood. Müssen wir alles durch die Streaming-Dienste nochmal vollkommen neu sehen. Amanda Lotz hat da ein doch sehr, sehr interessantes Buch vorgelegt, dessen Thesen ich vorstellen möchte. Und dann, wie angekündigt, die Auseinandersetzungen mit Habermas von Adam Tooze, von Paul Mason und Shijek äußert sich zum Krieg. Da muss ich ein bisschen Einspruch erheben. Ich habe schon angekündigt, ich muss Shijek auch mal widersprechen. Und noch Fukuyama fragt sich, ob seine Theorie noch stimmt.
Genau, in meinem Verlag, ich bin noch sehr gespannt, Letter in Support of Responsible FinTech Policy. Sehr namhafte Leute, Cory Dockdau, Bruce Schneier und so weiter, haben unter Concern.Tech einen Appell an den amerikanischen Politiker geschrieben, mal mit diesem Krypto-Quatsch aufzuhören. Wir gehen die Argumente mal durch. Es ist im Grunde schon eine Beerdigung von dem ganzen Krypto-Trend. Und ebenso wird auch beerdigt das ESG-Label. Wir kennen es. Vor 20 Jahren haben die UN angefangen, das so ein bisschen zu kreieren. Also auf die Umwelt, die sozialen Gegebenheiten und Corporate Governance einzugehen. Und die namhaften Leute, die das auch am Markt vorangetrieben haben, sagen jetzt doch, wir sehen es im Grunde gerade im Scheitern, insbesondere durch den Ukraine-Krieg, denn Rüstung und fossile Energiequellen, die ja da nun schon ein bisschen marginalisiert werden sollten, erleben ja gerade die lukrativsten Entwicklungen. Und in deren Sicht passt hier Ethik und Finanzmarktkalkül nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Und die Financial Times hat da mal den großen Rundumschlag gewagt. Und Paul Mason, nicht Paul Mason, Thomas Piketty, hat sich um Frankreich gekümmert. Da ist ja nun Parlamentswahl im Juni. Und er sieht hier ein Aufbruch-Fragezeichen. Die Blätter haben den Text aus Le Monde mal übersetzt. Da er sich auch für Deutschland einigt, mal gelesen zu werden. Jetzt ran an die Vermögen, werden wir das gleich mal lesen.
Dann sagen wir, bis gleich im Salon.